I
yoder's of a mad the Ouija here and as
you get as you can see Bethesda has
released a new short little teaser for
the perk big leagues in fallout 4 and
I'm gonna do an analysis of it just
going to go through the trailer in
slow-mo and get appointed some things I
think are noteworthy I just recorded
this and it was 15 minutes and that's a
little bit too long for a 14-second 14
to 15 second base video so we're gonna
try this again so we can seize level 42
got a kind of standard build nothing
none of his special status or too crazy
so we're gonna Kwan beam level 42 is
pretty crazy though one thing I want to
note about the perks is that when you
are when you have say in this perky or
even in big leagues you can see you he
has four and the fifth star is glowing
so we know that armor Smith and gun nut
I think it's called arm Smith I'm not
sure they have at least four ranks and
I'm gonna think probably for they could
have five but I would be really really
surprised if there was anything more
than that awareness only has one rank so
that's kind of just confirmed unless he
has there's another requirement that he
doesn't meet and one thing I do want to
note is this fifth rank of big leagues
where you can grand slam their head
clean off and you double damage melee
weapons which is an amazing boost to
your melee weapon damage is required to
be level 42 so you're not going to get
this until pretty late in the game
because you're it's going to take a long
time to be a little 42 and I think it's
gonna be similar to a lot of these
low-level perks that have multiple ranks
get the hyatt the higher you go in the
ranks I think the level required is
going to increase pretty exponentially
and what is interesting to note you can
go to the next prank previous rank is so
even if you don't have like say in this
this perk he only has one and you can
get to I would think if there's three
you can go over to that just you can see
the third rank of it so you can see if
you want to invest into that skill so
we're going to move on I want to keep
this not
18 minutes long and keep an eye this
animation is going to come up the
animation for this Burke is going to
come up every single guy big leagues is
going to come on every single time that
he gets a kill in this trailer which is
uh I think it just activate the skill
activating because he knocks their heads
off every time the trailer so we go
here's our sole survivor things I want
to note is that he has a melee weapon
and it's a single dot reticle I think it
will be different for guns I think
they'll have a standard us for line
reticle but so yeah that's interesting
and also he has a baseball bat that's
modified to have spikes in it nails
which is kind of cool and the biggest
thing i think i want to note in here is
that there is a layered armor system he
has his clothes on which is the baseball
uniform but then he also has this sash
belt that connects to his right arm
guard and you can see both the red and
the white under it so you know he has
that under this isn't just a like he
doesn't have right arm armor and then he
just has this instead he has the full
baseball uniform on and he also has his
right armor and this stuff which is uh
which is probably what they mean one
bethesda said that fella for is going to
have a layered armor system not much
else in this scene gonna move on all
right we have writer number one one
thing I do want to know is it's
interesting this pistol it's almost
entirely in the barrel and mechanisms of
the pistol the stock the handle
non-stock there's no stock the handle is
very minimalistic and hollow and even
the magazine is right here in the middle
of the gun and it's sticking out words
like you take 99 or type 100 from World
War two and so that makes me kind of
think it's going to be an automatic
pistol a lot of the Radia raiders seem
to have guns similar to this or this gun
specifically so it looks like this is
gonna end this is a little over eight ER
as you can see because when he executes
them when he gets the little an
animation going in the middle it is only
going to get a small amount of XP and
again there's another gun like that on
the ground here so I think a lot of low
Raiders and the level Raiders are going
to be using small kind of hand like
makeshift guns
because these don't look like super
standard-issue guns um the this person
could have a little bit of the layered
armor with these kneecaps and the shin
guards here and yeah it's kind of it for
this I do make note this body or
possible leg if it's just a leg and that
means there's a lot more dismemberment
in the game moving on just going to play
through this and then here we have
Raider scum which is a different type of
Raider obviously and there's a couple
dead bodies on the ground again that
pistol that that Raider had is here
twice he's holding one and there's one
of the ground he does have this Raider
scum does look like he has um does look
like he has layered armor and clothing
because you can see the clothing and
then also the armor on top of that like
barbed wire kind of metal stuff and
again he gets kind of low XP he got like
nine XP for that out of and there were
four XP markers that means we're gonna
be getting up to thousands of XP from
doing a single thing just kind of
interesting he hasn't used criticals in
any of the attack so far and he doesn't
use in this either so we don't really
learn much about crits one thing that
you want to note is that these Brahmin
are being domesticated and they are in a
pen in this um in his pen a little bit
of water and maybe some food troughs so
it's kind of cool this is in diamond
city as we can see because diamond
security and there's some just
townspeople just chilling out I do note
that this sign in the top left says GNN
that did make me think of galaxies news
something like Alex see news network so
I don't know if that's a hint at a radio
station or just a rang the billboard
that has no significant meaning this are
a guard does look like he has some form
of layered armor obviously is wearing a
modified umpires costume but looks like
there's some he's as clothing on
underneath it and if we go in see as so
there's a square signal on him right now
instead of the normal reticle which is a
dot for the melee weapon that's to talk
to him and as we hit him a lot of things
are going to happen so first thing first
this prop what is it called looting loot
menu shows up so we know that there is
time looting because this shows up this
doesn't pause the game so you can loop
things in real time without pausing the
game and probably go into a deeper menu
since there's this ellipse here so
there's more to do we can probably go
into deeper menu because uh that
possibly will pause the time and it's a
ma he has a mahogany baseball bat she's
kind of interesting so there are
different types of wood maybe that'll
come into play with crafting you can
craft different wood types of things and
again two more things off of killing
this guy is this little X signifier here
looks like a cross looks like a
hitmarker which I don't know how I feel
about if that is a hitmarker um I don't
know what if that's a good thing in my
eyes but it looks like a hitmarker
because it goes through as you hit him
and then it disappears and also you got
no negative karma for killing him which
is kind of a big deal because normally
in follow game you kill the guard that
would be instant negative karma and you
know that this guard isn't two beds
since I towards the very end of the
video you can see these townspeople turn
turn against you become enemies and try
and shoot you so you know the guard was
pretty chill and you killed them and you
didn't get any negative karma which is a
pretty interesting pack so the karma
system is definitely a lot different I
don't know what it could be but maybe
it's a lot more gray which is kind of
cool so that's kind of my analysis of
the trailer and you saw the the reticle
came back to normal the animation for
big leagues showed up again and the
townspeople have turned against you as
you can see from the red in the little
mini bar so hope you guys have enjoyed
this video keep looking at my channel
for more fall for content I will
continue to post it and yeah thank you
for watching peace up